the more we understand the neuro
chemistry have lived experience the more
we realized that we don't get to ever
really sample any kind of objective
reality right reality is coupled to
perception and perception can be
mediated right certain music can change
the way we process a scene a moment can
seem truthful or dishonest depending on
the tone depending on whether it's
cloudy or sunny depending on the place
in which you happen to dwell right so
again reality is mediated by perception
perception can be manipulated and so
brilliant people people will change the
world leaders right are said to have
this thing known as a reality distortion
field right Steve Jobs was made famous
for in his ability to distort to
italicize perception in his in his
co-workers right to inspire somebody to
see the world in a new way right
- literally engage the attention of all
these body minds and present with them
an alternative universe to make people
to bring them into your world to suck
them into your trance right and
literally engage them to probe the
adjacent possible right did not that
shadow phew
that hovers over the present that
provides a map of all the ways the
present can reinvent itself that's what
leaders do they distort reality but
here's the thing there's nothing fake
there's nothing in authentic about
distorting reality because the distorted
reality becomes real moment that
perception becomes the main operating
system the moment you adopt that vision
as truth it becomes truth mankind
decided we will fly it became truth
mankind creates technology that holds
space and time so the minds can
communicate instantaneously across
digital screen somebody hallucinate
AddThis technology into being we live in
a world where our thoughts spill over
and if they can harness the the will of
the people around us we can labor new
realities into being we can usher new
roles into being we can author realities
because we as human beings our greatest
potential is that we have this reality
distortion field we are like neo in the
matrix when he sees the code then he
flexes his muscle and space of time
warps around powerful metaphor but
that's we are that's rough wheel
you